ladies and gentlemen from The New York
Times drone again hits a Moscow building
housing Russian Ministries this was in
the wee hours of the morning but you
know what I gotta admit I don't care all
that much because this is not the story
you should pay attention to
this is the story you should pay
attention to hey why don't you read that
Ian we need the subject says a limited
Military draft I just didn't want people
to say that I'm the one saying that
because I don't think we do
military.com we need a limited Military
draft we then have the Council on
Foreign Relations the uncertain future
of the U.S military's all-volunteer
force from July 18 2023 which concludes
that uh we're going to need a new gates
commission to figure out how we how we
deal with this
Joe Biden has called The Ready reserves
and select reserves to be deployed to
Europe
over what's what's going on in Ukraine
and this operation has been ongoing
since 2014. Oliver Stone says he regrets
voting for Biden because Biden's leading
us into World War III you've now got and
it's not just these two op-eds more
calls for a military draft and you know
what the only thing I can say is I
really look forward to seeing Harry
sitting on the front lines making Tic
Tac videos yeah because they ain't
drafting the 37 year olds first well
don't be so Pie in the Sky man if if it
hits the fan well we're all on the
shopping block no yeah yeah I know but
what I'm saying is it'll be a good year
or so before they draft a 37 year old
over the 20 years what pisses me off is
that Biden gave that covid vaccine
mandate across the military a bunch of
people resigned or got kicked out and
now they're like trying to pull their
pants back up because they crapped their
diapers and like well in there
but I will add to that too and the
insane woke policy stuff there were a
bunch of things the Biden Administration
and million others had done which
decimated our our numbers forcing people
to to resign or just not want to enlist
at all
did you have something you were about to
say too oh well I was I mean you're not
going to send me to the draft I'll tell
you that right now I'm gonna die before
I go until I'm 23. so I'm the prime age
right well but but you're not first in
line yeah not first in line for a few
months at the same time it's interesting
because they've purged all these you
know right-wing extremists from the
military they've really been focused on
that but those those guys are the guys
that are fit those guys are the guys my
my friend Taylor okay you're 23 yeah uh
how tall are you I'm six foot you're six
feet tall yep uh how much do you weigh
178 178 and you work out a lot yeah you
lift yes yeah do you think they're going
to choose one of these uh soy boys
little five foot five weak noodle armed
antifa guys they're gonna be like I'm
the I'm the prime candidate but that's
what I'm saying I mean you're not gonna
get me you're not gonna get me
regardless of what you do I will die
defending my right not to go to war for
the military industrial complex
especially in Ukraine and we'll tell you
that in 10 years it's gonna be it
doesn't it won't much matter like the
physical fitness of the person because
they're going to be piloting drones and
wearing super soldier exoskeletons and
stuff have you seen no no no you're not
gonna win they're not gonna wear why
would you send a person in it's mostly
for Logistics
think about the generations that have
been raised on video games too that's
perfectly in sight with the technology
that the US military uses that's
literally what they're prepping you for
essentially and granted I love video
games but you're exposed to the violence
for a reason you're exposed to you know
doing drone strikes on people for a
reason because you know they're
basically prepping and grooming this
younger generation into accepting Wars
Boston to Canada man my dad was sucked
into Vietnam and it annihilated pretty
much everything in his life you know
along with his cousin and and God knows
however many members of that generation
he'd always tell me about the horror of
war in an unjust draft and I knew like
it was a dark fantasy of like what would
I do I'd have to I'd have to flee I'm
not gonna go die on some battlefield for
some oligarch I got too much to give to
this earth you're gonna for Joe Biden no
no no I'll defend this country I'm here
that's what the military is the future
of war is going to be those Boston
Dynamics robots the dogs I mean we're
just Terror got it right they've already
mounted machine guns to those dogs those
little robots I think that in biological
warfare everybody talks about nukes this
nukes that why would you use nukes when
you can use something that is
essentially untraceable I mean you see
with the covid lab leak that's the
future it's not so much that it's a
nuclear weapon destroys the city yep but
we want the city we want the city we
want the resources we want the the coal
The Ore the uranium
and so we want their civilians to be
part of our country well that's the
thing is DNA you get the DNA of certain
political leaders and their families and
you engineer bio weapons that only
target them yep and then the virus can
infect tons of people and nothing
happens but then all of a sudden these
particular individuals just
yeah that was great that RFK actually
mentioned that although he did get taken
out of context but genetically
engineered bio weapons that take out
certain types of human didn't they say
that he was being an anti-semite because
of that clip yeah is that the clip that
they tried to accuse me he made a noise
amplify it back at it he told the truth
oh he made a noise
yeah so you think that humans are not
gonna get like it's not gonna be as
human on human Warfare from above by
robots and like we'll just be watching
yeah I think sending in a wave of those
Boston Dynamics robots is look a nuclear
weapon will destroy the city we but we
want to own the city we want their
resources and we want to subjugate them
it may just be easier to unleash a virus
that targets a specific genetic profile
because we you sure you might want the
civilians but if you want to win the war
just erase the country just like that
even if you go down like the the
physical you know human on human kinetic
route you're going to end with robots
and all these things right there's going
to be humans thrown in the meat grinder
yeah it's not going to be it's not going
to be robots on robots it's going to be
robots slaughtering humans
it's going to be machines well not just
that it won't be just run by humans yeah
slaughtering others there's no reason to
wear an exosuit the um did you ever see
that short film about drone Warfare it
was just like 10 minutes about a guy
giving a TED talk about a drone wolf or
something like that and like it's people
running from building to building trying
to dodge these flying drones with
machine guns that are killing anything
that moves well you've seen the videos
out of Ukraine and Russia I mean that
they're drone Warfare have you looked at
have you seen any Drone footage
they're scary they're they're not big
you can't even see them a lot of the
time flying alone here flying bombs yeah
targeting your GPS coordinates you see
dudes just like like like this like
begging begging not to drop the bomb and
they just drop it and then there's that
one video they released where there's a
guy cowering in a foxhole yep and then
the Drone is pointing down and you see
the bomb just fall and then boom and
then the guy starts groaning and like
struggling moving again yeah well and
it's and those videos are I mean they're
everywhere I'm glad they're everywhere
they are everywhere but it shows the
realities of war and then there was that
one video of the ukrainians I think it
was like their their trans Tifa force or
whatever in that Minefield and they've
all got their legs
the guy jumps off the back of the truck
and he's just ready to land and kneel
and he lands on the on the thing well
then they go and try and help their
their friends you know that are down and
then they hit it the same thing too they
hit another mine I mean and the end of
it they all end up having I mean they're
missing limps dude the guy lands on the
landmine he gets his legs blown apart
and he immediately starts tourniqueting
himself like it's just horrific yeah
well and that's the thing is I think I
think the realities of War need to be
broadcasted but there's a reason why
they aren't any regular person sees any
of these videos It's Gonna disgust them
because frankly war is the most evil and
disgusting thing that you can do on this
entire planet I mean humans killing each
other for what for the idea that their
leaders are right and that the
international conflict is Justified I
don't think any International conflict
is Justified I mean when you have people
murdering each other because that's
exactly what this is there's I don't see
how anyone can say oh yeah I'm going for
Ukraine or I'm going for Russia no both
sides are at fault they're both
murdering people I understand resource
grabs like it's not good but if one
country doesn't have enough food and the
other one has more than enough and then
they're like coming in meditation trade
works way better than War it does
but then you need a Common Language you
don't need one but it sure helps you
need a common culture in order to keep
sustained trading you don't need it
history you know you said there's been
there's been cultures that were very
different have managed to trade with
each other and and remain very different
cultures and still live peacefully side
by side with each other simply put it
you don't have to keep killing it this
Russian thing is about a port it's a
land grab because they they want a trade
route and you can't buy a trade route I
mean they technically could buy the land
off Ukraine for 700 trillion or whatever
whatever the value over the next 80
years where they need access to that
right yeah
that freeway down to Crimea and and I
don't know if there's anything they
could buy it you could sell it to them
but at this point it's just Rubble I
mean I don't know do you know much about
what's going on is the Don Bass Just
leveled is it just a mud field I mean a
lot of things are just completely
leveled over there it is seriously
there's a reason why there's so many
videos out there in these especially
telegram telegram is the biggest
distributor of these videos that's where
you really see the uncensored stuff
um you put it on Twitter and even it
gets censored even on Twitter because
you're not supposed to see these things
I mean it's brutal it's the realities of
life and the realities of following
these dictators orders I mean and you
know I don't agree with Putin doing the
land room I don't agree with zielinski
casting out uh Catholics and Christians
I don't agree with any of this I think
everybody's in the wrong there's better
ways to go about I mean trade deals
right it's a perfect example you don't
have to kill each other just come to an
agreement come to a price and give each
other something that benefits both of
you that's the reality of how the world
is supposed to work but instead they'd
rather just murder each other because
that's where the money's at and it's sad
I mean it's truly heartbreaking
especially I have a lot of friends that
have come back from Iraq and these other
war-torn countries and they went there
thinking they were bringing democracy to
these people and then they get there
they are told to dehumanize these people
they kill these people and then they
realize oh these people don't want
democracy they're literally openly
saying they don't want democracy this is
a different culture and then the guys
come back the VA doesn't take care of
them it's the most disgusting thing I've
ever seen they swap them providers and
then these veterans kill themselves
because they have to deal with the fact
that they were sent over to murder
people under the guise of restoring
democracy thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time